Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier and welcome back to Dream Dad
Now we just got done with a beautiful date with Craig. It went wonderfully. We got a kiss on the head.
It was awesome. While I'm doing my afternoon word jumbles. I hear the mail truck pull through the cul-de-sac.
I wonder if we got any coupons today?
The nice mail person slides a couple letters in a large yellow envelope through this slot, takes a couple of tries for them to get in.
Hey my coupons. I take a closer look at the large yellow envelope.
I lightly knock on Amanda's door, she probably has headphones on. Manda! She yells through the door.
WHAT! I have something for you.
I'm kind of busy right now. Can you come back later? Okay? Just thought you'd want this big old envelope we got from HIA.
Immediately Amanda pushes her door open.
HORNE institute for the arts? I mean if you're busy I can come back. FATHER PLEASE.
I handed the envelope which she tears open with her teeth. That's probably bad for your teeth.
She doesn't seem to hear me and spits out a piece of the envelope.S he pulls a letter and unfolds it.
The suspense is killing me. This is her dream school, Amanda's face is unreadable.
I can't believe this.
Oh honey, it's okay if you didn't - I got in! It's that old joke, ha ha. oh! I got in!
Amanda tosses the letter aside and gives me a big hug. Congrats sweetie.
That's amazing. I'm so proud of you. She pulls away and looks at the letter again.
Oh my God I really can't believe it got in. Well of course you got in.
You're a great student, you nailed that interview and your photography is incredible. Wait, Dad.
I know this one's really expensive and it's so far away.
I think for a moment.
HIA was one of the most expensive schools that Amanda applied to, I know she's had her heart set on it for the longest time.
It'll be tough.
We're gonna make it work. I don't even know if I have a job or anything.
But maybe if I start working we can do something with that. Really? Of course.
Amanda hugs me again. Thanks Dad. Okay sweetie, we're celebrating today. Dinner, your choice. Wherever you want. Wherever?
Amanda I walk along the bay side,tearing into our foil wrapped burritos from nearby food truck.
You could have chosen anywhere in Maple Bay, cost was not a determining factor.
Please dad. I know - you know I'm a simple gal. Just give me a 'rito with a view I can't say I'm mad.
Amanda and I sit on a patch of grass and watch ships sail lazily through the bay. And the dorm is right near a bunch of cafes.
And there all these little galleries nearby, and there's a discount if you bring your student ID - Amanda slow down.
You're gonna choke on your 'rito.
I know.
I'm just excited.
Did I mentioned the students get their own studio space once they're seniors ? And we all get the professional photo editing software for free.
It's nice to see Amanda so enthusiastic about HIA. But I wish she wouldn't do it between bites of her burrito.
I thought I taught her to chew with her mouth closed.
I wonder who my roommates are going to be. You take a survey online and they match you with someone who's - with a similar major
and interests. I bet we're gonna be best friends.
Greg and I were a good roommate can be a lifelong friend
But don't even get me started on bad roomies. Oh, no. I'm just kidding
We didn't have a bad roommate our only other roommate was a puppy. - Craig brought home one night
We spent a semester
Fabricating the story about her new foreign exchange student had a really bad cough that sounded exactly like a dog's bark are
Carl RUULED
They let you have animals in the dorms but u  you need a note saying you need one
But I could forge one
I think I'd get a rabbit or maybe a snake or maybe both with the snake eat the rabbit though. Oh boy
I think I'll leave that all up to you. I'm so excited. I'd only disappoint her, but I need to be real for a second
So you know I had THAT talk with Mr. Vega
I didn't tell you about the dumpster fire did he? What no I don't want to put a damper on the good news
But I need you to knock it out of the park these last few months of school
Okay, if you really want to go to horns. We need that scholarship money. I know you can do it
Okay, I promise I'll try harder
I pat her on the back think you can handle a 14-hour drive to come home for the holidays
There's going to be some treacherous ice roads to cross. And don't even get me started on the paranormal occurrences
Well, it'll be worth it. If I get to see you. my eyes immediately well up with tears
Dad don't cry
Sorry, I'm just I'm just proud of you. You're all grown up and your such a good person...(incomprehensible mumbling)
Dad stop you're gonna make me cry too
It's too late honey. It's happening.
Dad I can't get tears in my burrito my rito
It's gonna make it taste sad pull the man in for a hug and kiss around the for love you kiddo
Love you too. Pops. Oh
Team Iplier away, ohh. OH Dad. I've got dads well...
I'm kind of committed here
The good old craig, but let's do a sweet save just in case we want to go somewhere else. Hey Craaig. What's up Craaaig?
What's up craig? I really want to get some good quality time in with Craig, last time we hung out
he was so busy with the kids and fending off flirty moms that I feel like we barely talked
Did get a sweet kiss on the forehead though. Ever since the first time we hung out
I've been trying to get up a little early for runs. I don't think I'm gonna be embarrassed as last time
Maybe I'll even be able to catch up with him now
Tap out a message. I'm on Dad books. Yo, what up CraAAig?
Been training on the run game. Ready for round two. Oddly enough, I have also been training on my run game look at for miles
Dude! Of course! Emojis!
I don't know I even just send an emoji rather than think about another message better than a bunch of eggplants in my inbox
another message pops into my inbox
Let's meet up early tomorrow for my favorite morning activity Brunch
Grow on that back brunch. What's that? Oh?
You run, and then you get brunch. Oh?
Right Greg and I agree to meet at a time in the morning
And I have a chance to spend the evening hanging out with Amanda
So we doing pizza tonight again can we do like
salad night
You want a health kick oh?
Not yet, I can form the committee to examine the possibility of being on a health kick
They haven't returned with their findings that if you go on a health kick
then I have to go and help kick by virtue of being under the same roof as you I don't know if I have the
Constitution for it
sir a minute which time craig needs big
Crag ditch be alright. Fine. Don't worry about it craig will forgive me. Maybe yeah Craig will forgive me
Committee spill out the committee isn't back with this finding yet. There's a multi-year assessment on Several bureaucratic levels well
Amana picks up the phone and stares at me unblinking as she dials hi
Yes
Can I get an extra large pizza with chicken bacon extra cheese and tomatoes and a couple of the garlic sauce cops man?
Going a little north here alright. Can you maybe throw on some leaves on there or something? Yeah? He's going on a health kick
Yeah, Rico. I know it's tragic made a list of per second on hold on. I'll ask dad is Oregano a salad
Curry, and I was totally salad yeah Rico
Yep, cash is fine stay out of the life and kids for me and Angry Rico says hey boo gets delivered
and we plop down on the cat's meat comes ah
good day of Rito's anza
Be careful running as Gateway drug
It's a slippery slope bag where's he going a couple of light jobs before you know you're converting the garage into a home gym
I'm renewing your subscription to some sort of Weekly Kombucha delivery service question
Q what's Kombucha ah?
So you are too far gone?
And I'm just giving you a hard time pops really happy you're running more caring about your health
I want to keep you around for as long as possible
Thanks kiddo speaking of which. I'm running this crag tomorrow. You're gonna be able to keep up with him pet no
Probably not we laugh anymore ah ah then he's probably healthy in the name of carbo-loading
I call him night early so that I'm ready for tomorrow
When I first started running in the mornings, it was pretty hellish now that I'm a few sessions
And admittedly has become a little bit easier despite. It always ending
Give me dry heaving over a trash. Can that what the runners is just dry heaving
I lace up my tennis shoes throw on a t-shirt from the writers summoned
I went to 20 years ago and head out the door a time a jug kraig is already outside with River strapped his chest
And that babies getting sick. He's dressed head-to-toe in color coordinated running gear wow
I look like a total slob next to this guy. I think anyone would look like a total schlub next to that guy. Hey, bro
Morning Craig Rivers gonna be running with us. Yes, you can we're taking it to the limit aren't we kiddo?
We've laid oh I know what you that means craig hands are stuffed toy. Which makes a smile ear to you
That's Arnold the capybara sometimes is the only thing that'll get her to stop crying
Oh, I've been there man a stuffed panda that she carried around everywhere
She would have a tantrum if we even tried to wash it. It's gross
Do you even running lately every morning for 30 minutes? I'm basically an elite athlete at this point, huh?
Well, I'll try to keep up where we added. I think that we can do a couple laps around the park okay?
That sounds reasonable, then we'll do some hill climbs up a slope
Okay, I can probably handle that double closed it off by doing some wilderness survival hike running to increase our agility that will jump off
Into the Ocean to swim with the Sharks punch you dick. It'll be all right cool
Buh go through the Sahara desert for about thirteen fortnight's I will have a good time over there traversing off as I malayan mountains
I'm suddenly struck with the overwhelming need to crawl back into bed. That sounds okay to you, right?
I usually like to throw sometimes Murder Sprints in there
But I'll go easy on you since you're a beginner so murder Sprint's you say
I know what that is and how nice that sounds that?
That sounds like something. I'm able to physically do great. Let's get started
Okay, cool
Greg and I finally arrived at the park a few other lone joggers make their way around the perimeter and river waves
Enthusiastically of everyone we pass so a lot more peaceful in the morning's aside from bird chirping and river gurgling away in the stroller
It's pretty quiet Roller
stroller
Patroller where's said Stroller all right. Good warm-up
Let's start the show
Wait Greg reaches into his bag and toss me a water bottle. I fumble it, but thankfully don't drop it. You got a hydrate, bro
Take a long drink from the water bottle in the field
Reinvigorated man, I don't drink enough water. Hey
I look down and pick up Arnold Rivers toy, and hand it back to her drop them thanks for looking out, bro
You ready bro. I?
buzzed
collapsing in on itself
We finally finished our however many teens lap around the park and breathing heavily. I can't believe actually didn't lose Greg
He's even breathing heavily - which makes me feel a little better. Look down my shirt notice. I'm drenched in sweat
Huh, almost looks like a frowny face. That's one new
What I'm just kidding good hustle out there. I'm really impressed you're way better than last time I launched you off a treadmill. Yeah
Man you really push me to my limit
Just now can't believe I held on sometimes you just go home
So I'm going to be there to push you to do your absolute best
Glad I could be that guy, bro
Yeah
We ready grill Klein's blap is my little cheerleader mark you ready oh
I'm just gonna give him moderate huh, I don't need to pull out oh here. Oh
There we go you bet
Greg takes me to a separate portion of the park here where there's a still
Steep climb that seems to go up forever. I strained my eyes to see some other joggers at the top
So what do we do now? We run up the thing that?
That looks like a lot mark
There's two things you need to know about this hill one. Don't stop running till you get to the top and two?
It points to the top of the hill. That's not the top
okay, now it's good time for the aw ah
I
finally reached the top of the hill after making
My way past what I originally thought was the top of the hill once there hunched over to my knees and gasps for air
My lungs are like daggers poking my ribs. I can feel my heart in my ears
Yeah, river. I'm having a moment, please oh
Greg looks like he's taking a beating as well, so we use human or quit your arms on your head and stretch out your elbows
It'll help you breathe better. I do its craig says it feels a little better
But I'm still in agony, and here greg tossing me the water bottle again a hydrate like my life depends on it
Thanks, dude, but now I'm gonna work you feel that lightness in your head. That's the Runner's high oh
That's it, but I was thought I was dying
Want to take it slow for a bit. I would like this please yes, please
We're catching our breath river starts crying. What's wrong sweet pea you want to play with Arnold greg looks around us
Oh boy, man down. I think we loved Arnold
River Keeps whaling I've abandoned my child
Kind of fine dude should be simple right we just got to retrace our steps
Remember River house having it at the bottom of the Hill great
And I jog down the path the searching high and low for the stuff
Capybara which Craig takes the time to explain to me as a large rodent native to South America
Get to the place where river might have dropped it, but it's still nowhere to be found
Looks like we've got a mystery on our hands
I have to get to the bottom of this I suspect foul play looks like this is a prime case for world Renowned detective
equally error the
newest a blare
Dude, it's time for a bro venture a pro venture
We high-five and decide to jog back to the park to see if we can find any lead
So it looks like there's a couple more places you're checking some bros around here. They'll get interrogate some good wait
Who's good? Cop who's bad cop?
Take it out for a second here from your back
I think that with your stature and overall resilience you would make an
Intimidating bad cop but on the other hand you do have an adorable baby strapped to your chest
So that softens the edges of it all valid points
I think you'd make a great good cop because you're congenial attitude and willingness to try new things
But then again see now you get when there are too many commercial breaks during the show
So you have the potential to be a scary bad cop I don't have to
Watch meet Helen three minute segments of five minute commercials in between loud commercials are too. Loud. I drive
every driver
Hey case in point. Let's play a Moment-by-moment. I'll be bad. Cop
So where do you protective? Oh yeah, go to the woods?
Good boys. Let's go to the woods
Don't know why?
why are we in the
woods we make our way to the oscars of the park there are a couple of benches by the dense tree line looks like
Roberts been here all by himself it also seems like the perfect place to look for clues
Interrogate Robert Robert
Excuse you Megara hair oh, hi. You're robert
Hey, call me then okay. Hi Robert. Don't call me that either okay? Hey
What are you up to you?
Thinking is my thinking bench. I have to get a solid two to three hours brooding per day, so in Chorus
If you by chance seen a small tough capybara around the capybara is is a large Road and headed to South America
I know do you see one?
Step one not a real one. That would be weird
That God I'll be back all right Robert. We've been nice elbows out
I'm gonna go off learn how to fight they'll come back here to kick your ass where?
you learned how to say jeez
Fine you don't tell us what we want to hear. I'm spoil the season finale of long Haul paranormal. I drago trackers
You're bluffing
My buddy. He doesn't play by the Rules Michael do it
Callum and fred crash into a haunted stop you monster
Robert sighs
Haven't seen any goddamn cat beer okay damn all that bad cop for nothing ha ha ha
So chloe forget I searched through the outskirts of the woods hoping to find anything to my latest Arnold
There are a couple of cigarettes and empty beer cans scattered around
It's probably the hotspot bridge teens hang out, and I say swears and stuff
It doesn't look like there were any recent activity that might be capybara related might be a dead end partner, bro
We return to the woods
Hmm. Well we already interrogated Robert. What would be the point of doing time to grill him again all right, okay? Would ya
Back up against Robert. I'm gonna keep being vaguely threatening gil you jealous. I'm the usual. I told you haven't seen a capybara
What you got damage damn again?
Sarah
We're an Abra go to play
we make our way over to the small blake around the edge of the park a couple of kids play on the jungle Gym my
Parents watch on nearby bench, we're on one of the benches. I spot a familiar face ah
Let's see what just incentive you engrossed in a book there, Jody. Do cousin nearly got the book -
Didn't think I'd see you guys out here mark. Are you exercising?
Shahram you know me. I just love to run and help. That's my kind of whole thing. What do you read?
Oh, just a book on knots and rope dang last weird, but okay
for boats bow gropes, right
Hey, you didn't have to see a stuffed cat bear around here. What's the capybara the large rodent it's native to South America Joseph
Thanks for a single hmm. I haven't seen one around. I'll tell the kids to keep an eye out
The kids are here does it look around they were here a second ago
Must have gone exploring around the park you know, how kids are
you know where they could have run up to their kids they get into mischief sometimes, but they always come back a
Little suspect Joseph
mischief you sick
Fuck viola wait am I being interrogated right now
Si. No, just doing our due diligence joseph
Arnold means a lot to river here. I mean if you're more than welcome to ask Christian Christie
I imagine they'd been ears to the ground on all the latest prague around drama they might be somewhere around the woods
Thanks you we'll get back to you. They give it a Roebuck
little dose
We head back to the playground look for clues Greg and I dude grown adults walk onto the playground and begin examining the meticulous
We could be clues no forensic evidence. No stray capybara after suit recruit lose your time
Look up all the parents staring at us my own weight as we awkwardly slink away. We've got a baby
Screaming that doesn't help our situation here, oh
Buddy got a rain check on Brunch need to get river home and calm her down alright. Good luck bro. Thanks, bro. Oh
no, oh
Did my date go badly?
Bullshit hang on wait no no. I'm not gonna. Do that no no no no no way. No way. No how no way
hang on here, aah
We bought time with the playground for river. I forgot to read, but that's okay
She's about to go nuclear this might prepare for the possibility of us
Not being able to find arnold life is cruel and tough but at least we need a always have swings
Craig Straps River into the baby swing gives her a gentle push
She giggles you can see it on the swing next door and immediately realism stuck
River seems to love that craig eventually helps me out of the swing and we decide to go back to the investigation all right
We're back on the case all right
Let's move on to another part of the park nothing here. Anyway a dead deuced where we should go next
God go to the
Fields we wander out of the grass field the center of the park during the whole lot to see but there a few figures camped
Out on a blanket
And the grass could hold any number of Secrets madame
Carmencita Soccer-Mad and his daughter carmen see the spots out from across the way
she's sitting down the dad on son a green patch grass we jogged over ah
Hey, bro
we just sat down for a picnic once and snacks and I think to increase my glycogen reserves uh uh
Have apple slices. Oh, thank you very much tiny bro, but I should be fine hey you guys working on a good day for it
Yep, I'm the picture of health and athleticism
Your drizzles mark. Have you seen a stuffed capybara around here anywhere or have you?
What's a capybara lard running his name is out of America wait a second
How do you know what a capybara is you wouldn't happen to have?
Hands-on experience or marceline would you we learned about capybaras in 4th grade? I think the more suspicious that you know what a capybara is
Hey, God, what if I were took arnold? What if I'm the culprit let's just go remember?
We checked my body buried polaroids. I may have kept on my person to remind me. Oh, I trust no not to trust
Some memento one that I'm pretty sure that's how it works
Anyway, nothing well what if that's what I wanted myself I?
Can't trust anybody especially myself. No mark. Don't let them win. Shake off the thought
I saw a couple of squirrels over by that tree
I don't know if that helps but if you want to see some cute squirrels, you should definitely check it out
Thanks for the hot squirrels tip
Tip Carmencita night well we better get moving got to find that capybara before the river as a breakdown
Good luck let's get some apples for the road. Oh carmencita hooks me up with some road slices. We're on our way
See ya back to the field
interrogate riff
Yeah, I'm a turkey wait
Let me try this
it's always the culprit you least expect I
Get I die with river who still looks on the shit like she's on the verge of tears nice
Nice. Yes, nice, and Care gave my baby. I'm a bad cop
Where's Arnold River starts crying uncontrollably whoops? Ohh? Ohh ow? Ohh ow, ohh?
Nope. Nope that didn't happen that wasn't the way that works that didn't happen everybody no one remember that I yelled that up
Baby, hey, Sweetie believe me. Nobody wants to find a capybara more than me. We need clues
I think somewhere in that baby brain of yours you might have something that leads us to the perp. What is it?
I turn to craig. We're getting nowhere with the witness. Oh all right fine, men check out the squirrels cool squirrels
What did the suspects say the squirrels would be tree uh-huh there? They are?
Yeah, Carmencita was telling the truth is some rats squirrels river seems
Happy this may have bought us some extra time all right any clues see can't seem to find them while I'm looking
Craig calls me out from across field mart hi. I jogged over craig is kneeling in the grass inspecting something
I approached my herd my throat as I leaned over craig. I see it. This is Arnold
I
Put my hand over rivers eyes. No one should have to be subjected to this senseless violence
my God
Or what do this? I don't know I think we might be dealing with something Beyond our grasp
I can't look at this anymore turn around trying to wipe the image of stuffing strewn across the ground from my mind
How we're running out of time? We may already be too late?
Bagged and tagged it let's keep moving back to the field
Clock's ticking dude, we're going next
This is the big Kahuna. Ain't it. I think we got to go back to the woods something about Robert don't rub me right?
Last night, but that's not the point Joseph's twins must be around here somewhere Robert
Hey, okay. She said not again. See Robert hello Roger
Gavin where crap ah
Now what bro just excited twitter around here somewhere, but I have no idea why would go to find them
We there's Tp kids you didn't tell me they had something to do with these, huh?
maybe I should have left a good cop bad cop Routine to the Pros and
Yeah Robert, bro
Do you know where they are I do a lot of people underestimate the sense of a man who broods a sudden lurking?
Near Little while ago where they go ran into the woods pretty careful though. I don't trust him, but then again
I don't trust anymore not even you guys not even that baby yet. I could get back
You know silky dough. Thanks for your help Robert go deeper into the Earth visit
This is the one let me say just in case of work to the purge in
Which I stare into the depths of the forest who knows what could be in there
Are you prepared for what we might face in there?
Not at all on second thought. I think they might be able to smell the fear on me
Maybe we should give that in a minute to dissipate seconded the woods. Oh
Wait, no hang on. No that's not what I wanted yeah, I'm ready ready partner, bro
you know, but if you give Rivers to stop crying
I don't care let's do this we'll start down the path into the woods keeping their eyes and ears peeled for any sign of Arnold
Words anywhere, the silence is unsettling the sun can barely peek through the canopy. It's colder here
Suddenly we hear voices. I want to do it
You're gonna do it last time I come to a clearing where I find Kristen Christina kneeling over something
Right there criminal Scum for your tiny hands where we can see him?
Kristen and Christie just stare at us you heard the guy put your hands up, okay in the middle of something here. Yeah
Can you come back later you kids doing cutting stuff up?
Artists bounding is this the end of the line step closer? I can't believe what I'm seeing pair safety scissors slide the Durden
It's Arnold. What's read under?
Arnold Dube
You're the baby hand over the capybara fair finders keepers
No, not finders keepers. That's our property and you desecrated it
How can you prove it's yours craig holds up arnold severed leg they have to look away
You got sloppy you left evidence behind back it can find it this leg fits perfectly onto his body
Christian Christie look at each other. They don't know what to do
How about a deal you can muster capybara, and we won't tell your dad about this
fine
Hand over the stuffed animal give us some safety scissors there clearly no longer safe in your hands she hands them over
Glad we can figure this out come on partner
Craig, and I start making our way out of the woods he turns around and calls back to the twins
No, your dad to stop letting you watch true Crime Joe's with the calavera back with its rightful owner Craig
And I shamble into a nearby diner exhausted from our adventure
We find ourselves a corner Bruton's settle in that was a tough case we cracked it, bro
We're different now changed if we get in too deep night nothing hardy Bronze can fix my stomach grumbles
I suddenly realized how big of an appetite. I worked up brunch. Give me brunch
I have a strong philosophies on Brunch
You see the first thing you do is divide your brunch is between boozy brunch and upper-class and the most is eggs
Benedict brunch and Grimy brunch, then give me a coffee and bacon cheesy hash Browns brunch
There's time in a place for both, and I think most of life is figuring out which one
Some kind of brunch dad are you mark God give me a grimy brunch every any day?
I don't need a boozy brunch get me grimy. Oh make it fried annoying I clean the floor with the homes
Oh happy fine choice. The way what's going on a health kick got a got a Carbo load get a Carbo load. I'm carbo-loading
Carbo no blank amount of cheesy potatoes o'brien to refuel after a run rye bread
It's not even remotely how carbo-loading works
All right even who's your kid? Oh, you betcha. She's so cute. How you?
done
Hey, kid Middle school is gonna be real tough, but if you make it through then you can make it through anything
The weight just walks away after winking at Craig seems like you're the most eligible Dad and Bachelor town
Okay, so anywhere. Here's the thing about brunch
You don't do business during brunch brunch is a time for rest relaxation and restoration with those that you love
While we're having brunch at a traditional ebro time the most important thing to remember is that brunch isn't a time?
It's a date of mine tonight. You can't have brunch on your plate. You can always have brunch in your heart, I
Disagree with you. I just don't know if I could match your identity uh-huh I'll open your eyes, bro
this way
You're our food in the waitress after very blatantly hitting on Craig multiple times
Eventually brings our brunch east River munches on cereal right next to us
More or less managing to get it into our mouths I gotta say man
Feels great having you back around to hang out with I think you've been so busy with work and fitness and kids just
Haven't had time to really go out and get to know people
With you here. It's like picking up where we left off
There's a feeling man if a new new place could have been really rough for me, especially with the Manna going off to college soon
Making this a lot easier Craig smiles at me. Yeah
Feels really good to go another bro venture with you dude. Just like old times for a while
I forget about it anything. That was bothering me in my life, and it was just you man
Well copy oh
So do you like work out?
Yeah, mostly calisthenics, but I try to lift as part of the regimen. It's so cool. I've been looking for a workout buddy, and then
Ah wish I could help you out, but I'm enjoying brunch with my workout bro right now. Hello. I'm here. My name is Markiplier
Oh well
if you change your mind
The waitress slides a folded note Craigan walks away Craig makes a face and reluctantly puts it in his pocket
We can't take you anywhere can we do another half?
It's a blessing and a curse isn't it
Next time we hang out to be in the middle of the woods
Where people can't interrupt us and also maybe in some different woods than the ones
We were little kids like to vivisect things greg laughs man remember all our camping road trips back in the day
Joshua Tree. Hell, yeah, yellowstone. That was the best give anything to do it all over again
Dude, we should go on a camping weekend. Oh, I don't know bro. I don't know have all these old responsibilities
I don't think I could just drop everything to hang on the woods for a few days. You know come on
Dude if we blandings, right we can do this greg don't you ever do anything for yourself?
Creek Scares Andrews government of course I do
Yeah, like what sometimes to let my help sell that one vanilla ice cream before bed
but only if I didn't mean my caloric intake for today
Sometimes I let myself hit the snooze alarm, but only once dude you gotta relax sometimes, or it's Gonna kill you okay?
Please come camping with me. It'd be so fun, bro
They could get smashley to take the kids for the weekend
I'll think about it. Oh
We finish our brunches and head back to the cul-de-Sac
By the way great job keeping up today seems like you're already making a lot of progress
I'm probably gonna need a little bit of recovery after this tell the girls. I said hello, I will see you protective. Oh
Say goodbye to correctly step inside gotta marry for a shower gallon water in a nap now Dead Amanda's still asleep
Crack open her door to find her still in bed sleepily scrolling through her phone
Mornin
afternoon actually
Right, how is Brunch?
Good we kind of got sidetracked
Before because we had to travel into the depths of maple a dark underbelly to find a toy river drop
But you know I actually feel pretty good. Yeah
I miss all on the floor of the hallway. I'm just gonna hang out here for a while. You take your time didn't up
See you around the bend
Hey
I got that boy ah
I don't know you're amazing. I guess it's out of your college. I missed you dude. Oh
That's so nice
oh
Anyway, so that is the end of this episode. God. I love this game. So fun
It's so fun anyway, so thank you everybody so much for watching I'm gonna keep going on with this
I don't know how long there's a lot of data to date out there
So thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video
~Buh Bye~